pourquoi marine le pen refuse-t-elle de
venir sur le plateau de c'est à vous
malgré nos nombreuses invitations
répétées écoutez vous pourrez poser
d'abord la question emmanuel bacon
pourquoi est ce qu'il a refusé toutes
les émissions du service public dans la
campagne non mais il faut être juste je
vous rappelle qu'il était ce matin tu
l'as info qui va demander
à vos confrères la même maison à vos
confrères de france evian de là deux des
quatre vérités
un rapport qui tombe mal pour marine le
pen celui de l'office antifraude de
l'union européenne selon mediapart ils
accusent la candidate du rassemblement
national d'avoir détourné 140000 euros
d'argent public européen à des fins
personnelles ou pour de la politique
nationale alors même qu'elle était
eurodéputés de 2004 à 2010 est un
rapport transmis au parquet de paris ma
question la présence de marine le pen
dans l'émission je ne vous cache pas en
revanche que il arrive que dans
certaines émissions
certains journalistes peinent à
dissimuler leur hostilité à l'égard de
marine le pen et quand elle estime
qu'elle ne peut pas exprimer ses idées a
déjà exprimé vos idées est ce que vous
partagez les inquiétudes bien sûr j'ai
toujours été très bien reçu et je suis
très ravi de venir les défendre il ya
encore des journalistes faut pas qu'elle
fasse présidente à moi j'oublie comme ça
le président du rn jordan bardella a
réagi et dénoncé une tentative des
institutions européennes pour s'ingérer
dans la campagne et pour nuire à marine
le pen rappelons que la candidate et
déjà mises en examen depuis 2010 est
pour des soupçons d' emplois fictifs au
parlement européen
une femme célibataire à l'elysée ce
serait inédit en effet depuis cinq ans
voit une femme ce serait inédit ja les
câlins c'est mieux maintenant que
c'était mieux avant alors là je beaucoup
mieux là on est beaucoup plus peut-être
désinhibé et les cas loeb ils sont moins
nombreux ils peuvent être plus profond
profond pas au sens et voilà j'ai bien
compris vous avez monsieur cohen que
vous m'avez reçu à plusieurs reprises
depuis maintenant depuis les élections
européennes deviendra et c'est vrai qu'à
plusieurs reprises vous avez un peu de
mal à dissimuler votre hostilité à notre
égard donc à ce que vous pouvez dépasser
martin j'en avais marre des là c'est pas
mon hostilité s'il ya une semaine c'est
ma connaissance du front national que je
suis est depuis et vous surveillez le
fait que vous l'aviez encore l'été
nationale était oui je dis oui c'était
un front national on apprend à 17,18
quand tu commences à succès le foin
[Musique]
[Rires]
d'abord il faut trouver de la place pour
avoir un homme dans sa vie quand on fait
ce que je fais déjà et puis ça se
présente pas voilà et donc je pense
qu'on peut vivre en étant célibataire on
peut être heureuse en étant célibataire
enfin julien moi j'ai des j'ai des amis
j'ai une famille donc je ressens pas de
manque particulier mais je n'ai pas fait
une croix sur toute vie sentimentale
bien sûr
[Musique]
moi je vous propose effectivement la
terre nourricière qui va pouvoir vous
régénérer vous nettoyez et vous allez
pouvoir effectivement remettre se montra
c'est comment je me nourris et être
indépendant tout en communion sur la
terre cela avec laquelle je vis c'est
très beau et donc
vous avez rendu hommage la votre épouse
celle qui m'importe le plus qui
m'apporte le plus qu entendez-vous par
là quelque chose de
très intime mais parce que nous
partageons nos vies depuis quelques
années maintenant
je pense que
quand on occupe ses fonctions il faut il
faut garder un équilibre intime et
familiale
et grâce à elle je les
connaissais déjà il
c'est vrai c'est vrai non mais c'est
vrai ça virait d'une chambre moi je
t'avoue que je connaissais pas du tout
s'il vit dans cet égard les gars rigolos
les gars caméléon moi je connais et
sylvie de caisse il faut rentrer chez sa
directrice d'école c'est de gratter à la
fenêtre
je pense pas qu'on puisse et exercer ses
fonctions et décider s'il n'y a pas un
équilibre affectif